dass gerade so ein bisschen chaotisch
andererseits muss auch dazu sagen möchte
ich nicht an der stelle von irgendeinem
politiker sein der um welche
entscheidung treffen muss ich finde es
ganz schwierig möchte nicht mit frau
merkel tauschen in der heutigen zeit
ganz ehrlich weil die haben natürlich
seine zeit auch noch nicht erlebt
deswegen ist es einmal schwierig klar
schimpfen klar ich bin auch manchmal ich
so denke mein gott eltern ist die kacke
jetzt mal zu ende
aber es dauert noch eine weile noch also
dieser virus wird ja nicht weg gehen und
dann nicht mehr da sein der wird uns
einfach unser leben lang begleiten wir
müssen jetzt aber gucken dass wir die
kurve kriegen
ich finde es fehlt auch so ein bisschen
mehr an informationen für den
normalbürger das hat sich jetzt blöd an
aber es ist und man wird zu wenig
informiert mal funktioniert der
impfstoff funktioniert nicht meine
mutter sagte neulich ich habe angst mich
impfen zu lassen weil jeden tag ist
ebenfalls neues oder so es ist so ein
chaos einfach da und keiner danken kann
damit umgehen und man braucht sich auch
nicht wundern dass die leute und wann
ausbrechen und sagen so geht es nicht
weiter und ich habe den größten respekt
eigentlich vor den leuten die in diesem
ganzen sozialen bereich noch einmal ein
pflegeheim krankenschwestern natürlich
sagt man früher standen alle auf dem
balkon abgeklatscht klatsch keiner mehr
das ist auch so aber ich brauche noch
nicht klatschen ich man muss die leute
anders unterstützt man muss ihm halt
mehr kohle zahlen das ist einfach so es
geht einfach nichts muss schneller
bezahlt werden ich weiß auch nicht woran
scheitert weil die gelder sind ja
angeblich da das ist glaube ich das wo
man die leute denn zufriedenstellen
könnte in erster linie brauchen jetzt
aber auch nicht anfangen darüber zu
gehen als krankenschwester zu wenig geld
verdient das war schon vor jahren so
aber es gibt ganz viele die halt
versuchen die von ihren ersparnissen
leben
die einfach wirklich sagen okay ich habe
jetzt noch zwei monate und dann ist
vorbei und für die müssen wir eine
lösung finden